jackie robinson day always one of the
most special days
in baseball 42 is the most sacred number
in all of sports
and what jackie did and how he carried
himself with such grace and dignity
throughout on and off the field was
absolutely amazing 32 years old a year
ago oral he had one of the best eras in
the american league at 369 but that 675
is the second worst in baseball
two on nobody out here's turner swing
and a miss and turner strikes out that's
the first out of the inning
this ball hit on the ground sharply to
first dietrich great job to flag it
just gets it to first in time to beat
ballinger that's a
3-1 put out in the scorebook 1-1 on the
ground third base
should be a routine out it is and the
inning is done no runs two hits two left
after a half inning it's the dodgers
nothing and the rangers coming out
on the mound it's going to be dustin may
he pitches about 30 miles from his
hometown tonight
yeah he's got a string of 10 starts in
the big leagues where he's given up
three earned runs or less
followed into the glove strike three one
away mate
on the year now 21 strikeouts seven
walks
made looking for a one two three first
line drive right field mookie bets to
the second we go in texas on jackie
robinson day
no score taylor eating 255 two homers
and
nine runs bad and the o2 called strike
three
second strikeout tonight for minor he
definitely caught taylor looking for
something other than a fastball
here comes the payoff pitch swung on and
skied into short right field
gallow coming on underneath it he's got
it
smith is out so are the dodgers one two
three and we head to the bottom of the
second and the rangers are cooking here
in the second runners at first and
second and
nobody out may out of the stretch comes
home
and a big bouncer up the middle tanner
waits on it steps in the bag and throws
to first for a double play
and just like that may is on the
doorstep of getting out of this city
with no damage
on an o2 goes to the breaking ball it's
punched in the ground a second there's
fernandez that's the inning
four pitch walk for [ __ ] hernandez to
open this inning so brings up mookie
batts
the 1-2 pitch that's in there for a call
third strike miner records his
third strikeout of the evening that's
the first out here in the top of the
third
another chance for the dodgers here
another chance for turner
turner in the air out to center field
back near the wall and tavares
leaps up to make the catch second out of
the inning
hernandez advances to third but a nifty
play in center by leote tavares
great speed on board here for shinsu who
struck out his first time
the 1-1 pitch lined past turner into
left the base hit
tavares at third he comes in easily two
digging for second here's the throw
he dives he's in ahead of the throw rbi
double for shinsu chewing a one-nothing
texas rangers league here's the o1
the swing and a looper into right field
bets won't get to this one it
dunks in for the knock trotting in to
score is shinsu chew
two-nothing ranger dodgers have
something brewing here with runners at
first and second one out
here's the o2 a swing and a line drive
into right gallow has to move just a
couple of steps to his left to make the
catch on that
slightly slicing line drive the 2-2
swing and a miss he chased a fast ball
away and miner strikes him out a couple
of punch-outs for mike here in the
fourth
seeger has singled and walked tonight
two nothing texas
here's the pitch swing and a miss he
struck him out off speed up and in to
get seeger
he has pitched around three walks one
ball two strikes
there goes the running the pitch is
swung on looped in the air to short
right field gallow coming on and over
towards center
he's got to be his leader retired aside
mike miner has sewn the ball
really well so far he's allowed the four
hits worked around three walks
and this one flared caught it short
stopped by kinder philippa
got up the ladder pulled that one down
two away a one pitch a swing and a
grounder right into the shift
connor falef's got it on the first base
side clings it over to first it's a one
two three inning for mike miner
now yoeli rodriguez is the first man up
out of the bullpen
top of the order mookie betts coming up
the o2
swinging a miss he gets the fastball by
him looks like he was trying to lift and
separate with this baseball and hit a
long way
there now over nine with runners in
scoring position and here's seeger
lying to center field and deep back goes
to varys and it's over his head
smith and to score the first run of the
night for the dodgers on a ringing
double from corey seeger it's 2-1
ferrari rodriguez sets and fires and
turner
pulls one to left sinking quickly down
for a base hit
heinemann up with it here's his throw
home way off line and this game is tied
swinging a miss turner was running and
he's stolen
second first stolen base of the year for
him and he's wincing after
he shortened his stride the last four or
five steps into the bag
you see him change his stride length
like something was tightening up
justin turner is coming out of this game
jake mcgee comes on the pitch in a brand
new game
tied at two yo one dietrich lifts it
high into the air fairly deep left field
pollock going back he turns to look it's
gone derrick dietrich
lefty on lefty with an opposite field
home run his
second and the home team goes back in
front here 3-2 for one down we go back
to the top of the order in shinsuke
ready to deliver the one a ball hit back
up the middle
and that gets through for a base hit
connor falefa comes in to score
and he makes it 4-2 rangers 1-2
in the air right field toward the alley
that one gets down
a run is in five two rangers
the dodgers are down to their last stop
ontario's one
two got him swinging and rafael montero
with a perfect ninth inning
rangers take the opener six to two